Pamela Anderson in her own words yep
fans are getting their first look at the
upcoming Netflix documentary Pamela a
love story ahead of its release on
January 31st that's right the 55 year
old is aiming to take control of the
narrative for the first time as she
seems to address the 2022 Hulu limited
series Pam and Tommy which explored the
events surrounding her and Tommy Lee's
stolen sex tape and the subsequent
release online yeah honestly I feel like
we've all been waiting for her to make a
comment about this now amid the release
of that series many reports reveal that
Pamela felt violated and that the series
has been very painful for her however
Pamela has remained silent on the series
and is vowing to tell the real story in
her own documentary now we have not seen
the trailer yet so Morgan let's take a
look together oh I can't wait and we'll
share our thoughts afterwards let's do
it
I didn't sleep last night at all if
anybody's watching this go to hell
I blocked that stolen tape out of my
life in order to survive and now that
it's all coming up again I feel sick
I want to take control of the narrative
for the first time
[Music]
public property
I didn't feel like I had a lot of
respect would you want to be a serious
actress I'm a serious actress
I had to make a career out of the pieces
left but I'm not the Damsel in Distress
I put myself in Crazy situations
and
survived them
I don't care what people think because
that's the only choice I had
if I care what people think I wouldn't
be here
[Applause]
some men think oh she's the Playboy
thing or the sexual person
and they hate you for being something
else
maybe it's your favorite thing in the
world is falling in love I love you I
love the idea of pulling out of love too
one man can't do it all
[Music]
oh
love me say that say that you love me
you have to be brave and you got to use
what you got
why can't we be the heroes in our own
life story
here
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I am seeing this I love Pamela
Anderson I know you know you're a bit
younger than me but like Baywatch was
everything I love that she's Canadian I
interviewed her recently for her HGTV
Canada series uh Garden of Eden Pamela's
Garden of Eden because for me she's
quite private you know back in the 90s
and the early 2000s she was everywhere
but she really took a step back and I
think unfortunately when a lot of people
think of Pamela they think of the sex
tape they think of the marriages they
think of Baywatch the bathing suit
um so I love that we're finally gonna
hear from her I also felt so bad for her
when that series came out last year
listen I know Netflix and Prime video
and you know all these all these uh
different streaming platforms create
these stories based on a lot of people
and the tragedies they face and famous
people I just felt sick though because
this is considered one of the first
viral things and she you know we know
how many people who put out sex tapes to
make careers she didn't do that on
purpose and I just felt so bad that this
was starting up all over again people
are going to watch the tape again so I
love that she's owning it yeah like you
said I'm a bit younger so I'm not too
aware of this whole situation but what I
do know is that when when you when you
say Pamela Anderson the first thing that
pops into your mind is that sex tape of
course being an over sexualized woman so
I think that it's huge that she's taking
control of her life like she said it's
my turn to write my own words and I
think that's just like the biggest move
that she can do at this point like I
just I really respect it I'm excited to
see that and you know she's really down
to earth she's very sensitive I think it
was her son who said in the trailer like
she is in love with love she's been
married numerous times but it's because
I think she's always looking for that
right partner for herself because I
think she just wants to settle down and
be happy and live on her property in BC
like this HGTV you know series shows and
I love that series if you haven't seen
it yet
um so I honestly can't wait for this but
it is wild when you see those images
from her in the 90s and like that was
just embedded in my childhood she was
like the biggest thing wow you know so
can't wait to hear her own words she's
Canadian so we want to see her win yeah